time is running out the words of u.n
secretary general antonio guterres after
he unveiled a new plan to urge countries
to switch to renewable energy sources he
said if the world did not end fossil
fuel consumption we would quote
incinerate our only home
he was speaking as the world
meteorological organization published a
new report with some bleak conclusions
for the future of the planet if
emissions are not reduced among them
more heat waves of the type that's
currently making life all but
unbearables for millions in india
it's a heat wave that one in six people
on earth are currently struggling
through
blistering heat has scorched india and
pakistan for weeks
on the weekend temperatures hit a record
high of 49 degrees celsius in the indian
capital delhi
i'm 74 years old i've never seen new
delhi go through this much heat ever in
my life we used to hear about the heat
in rajasthan we used to think of it as
an unfortunate event when rajasthan used
to go through 48 degrees celsius this
year all the records have been broken
climate change has already made extremes
like this hotter
and more likely
the heat has killed crops and hurt
harvests
the farmers themselves can't catch a
break either
the heat makes us thirstier we're also
exposed to more heat we have to work
with cloth wrapped over our head and if
we don't we'll get a headache we cannot
afford to stop working
heat makes people less productive
but staying outside for too long as many
workers and even children are forced to
do can cause fatal damage to organs
temperatures will keep rising as long as
people continue to burn fossil fuels
in a bid to keep weather extremes like
this from wrecking communities world
leaders in 2015 promised to limit global
warming to 1.5 degrees celsius this
century
the average increase might not sound
like a lot
but the effect it has on extremes
is a matter of life and death
well within the studio is dw environment
reporter ajit niranjan who filed that a
report uh tell us about this the key
findings of this new report from the
world meteorological organization so
last year the world broke records for
four critical indicators of the health
of the planet of the climate now the
world meteorological organization
recorded levels of greenhouse gas
pollution in the atmosphere that he had
never seen before
it saw that oceans have become hotter
they've become
higher sea levels have risen
and they become more acidic as well
now all of these things are alarm bells
that tell us about the health of the
climate and the planet and show that
this trend of worsening weather extremes
is only going to get worse but what the
report also documented clearly was that
these extremes are already here they're
already happening some of them are
attributable to climate change climate
change has made them worse or more
likely and this is already causing more
than 100 billion dollars of damage each
year right i mean people in india are
now experiencing
the effects there uh tell us more about
the consequences of this kind of heat
so the consequences are really
far-reaching you can have day-to-day
life just being made unpleasant and
uncomfortable for weeks on end i mean
people are struggling to just do basic
tasks like going to school going to work
doing the grocery shopping for people
who have to work outside as we can just
saw in the report farmers builders
outdoor laborers
this can really be deadly and many don't
have a choice they have to work they
can't afford to stay at home but the
effects really reach well beyond india
and pakistan as well as borders because
i mean we're seeing
damages to crops and farming that have
knock-on effects for the entire world so
the world meteorological organization
report already outlined that by 2021
this compounding crisis of climate
covered conflict had already undermined
decades of progress towards reducing
hunger in the world now on top of that
there's a war in russia and ukraine
there's also in india heat wave that are
killing crops
now talking about india india has been
accused by environmental organization of
single-handedly torpedoing the 1.5
degree target that you also mentioned uh
in your report with its strong reliance
on coal to meet its energy needs i think
it's it's
three-quarters of uh the energy needs of
india is
met by by coal will this extreme heat
change minds in india both in the
government and maybe also in the
population
it's hard to see when we've seen extreme
weather events rock countries like
germany australia in particular which
have
terrible wildfires in recent years
these countries have we've seen some
level of societal awareness about
climate change increase but it's very
hard to actually identify whether it
really changes people's minds about this
with the indian case it's also perhaps
important to stress that india is one of
many countries that is pushing the world
beyond this 1.5 degree temperature
threshold that world leaders promise to
try to keep us to and i mean if we just
compare a country like germany so here
in germany you and i
burn essentially more coal
than the average indian does because we
use a lot more energy in germany
per capita it's a different story isn't
it and so
when i speak to climate scientists in
india i mean one of them recently told
me that i mean the key thing that india
can do now is come up with good heat
management plans but she also stressed
that there are limits to that level of
adaptation that on top of that countries
like india and other developing
countries or poorer countries need to
put pressure on high emitters that are
also continuing to invest in fossil
fuels and switch to cleaner sources of
energy
so
what can be done to avoid these weather
extremes briefly so there are two main
things cut the pollution and adapt to
the effects of it and both of these
things are doable and they're within
reason and they often have a lot of
benefits for society if we switch to
renewable sources of energy we reduce
air pollution which stops people dying
from lung disease at the same rate
if we adapt to the extremes that have
already become worse then we can also
strengthen society and build it in a
more sustainable way so this is they're
clear-cut solutions and scientists are
very insistent now we know what to do
thank you very much ajit niranjan
our environment reporter thank you
well earlier i talked to professor
pateri tallas the secretary general of
the world meteorological organization i
asked him whether the paris agreement
had failed or just simply not been
enough
so we have seen progress we also saw
progress
at glasgow climate conference last
november
uh the g7 countries the richest
countries and european union they were
making blazes to keep us
on this 1.5 degrees track but the rest
of g20 countries
countries like china
india russia brazil south africa they
were not ready to make such splashes and
that's why we are not yet heading
towards 1.5 degrees we are rather
heading towards 2.5 to
3 degrees warming
well what else can be done then
so so we have to convert our energy
systems to be dependent on on renewable
energy nuclear energy and also find
energy saving means we have to convert
our transport system to be more based on
electric vehicles
public transportation and perhaps
hydrogen in the in the future and and we
should also stop uh deforestation
especially in tropical rainforests and
and and also favor more vegetarian
diet
because these rainforests are very much
cut to to feed
cattle and and
produce for example
soybean so and and
and this overall consumption is of
course
an earth issue and especially if you buy
goods that are produced by using a
coal-fired nsc that's that's also one of
the one of the challenges and
opportunities to become more climate
friendly
but what can how can countries be
convinced to significantly up their
carbon reduction commitments
it has been
demonstrated clearly that
also from economic perspective it's
going to be much cheaper to mitigate the
climate sense than to live with the
consequences of
climate change it's even
up to 20 times more expensive if we let
the
climate change to happen and we are not
able to mitigate it so it's also
financially
viable to to to pay attention to climate
the mitigation and and start using this
climate friendly means means
to produce energy
in transport sector and also other
sectors that we are dealing with
now lately we've seen this extreme heat
in india and pakistan but we've also
seen other extreme weather events what
other effects can we expect within the
next five to ten years
so this negative trend in in climate
will continue for the coming decades
anyhow and we have already lost this uh
glacier melting and sea level rise game
that will continue for the coming
centuries because already high
concentration of
of of carbon dioxide and and that means
that we have to pay also at attention to
adaptation and one very powerful way to
adapt to climate change is to invest in
early morning
services and even in countries like
germany
there seems to be an opportunity to
improve
those for example this planning event
that took place
last summer
could have been a handle much better and
we could have
avoided casualties if the hydrological
services would have functioned in a
better manner
professor pateri tala secretary general
of the world meteorological organization
thank you for joining us on
dw thank you